these webinars have been recorded and
there's a place
if you didn't know this there's a place
you can access all of these recordings
um and they're just a wonderful resource
a wealth of information from all of the
different coaches and
as you may know um udacity has decided
to
end the one-on-one career coaching
services
as of the 24th of march and so
that in the hotline uh
let's see uh the career channel hotline
is going away
but you will have access to all of the
webinars that have been recorded
um i actually did this webinar back in
october and forgot to record it so i
asked to do it again it was a fairly
popular
um uh webinar and it was one of my
favorites to
uh present so um that's why you see me
here today
and so anyway we're going to go ahead
and get started
um this webinar is a little bit heavy
in terms of content but i would invite
you to
please ask questions i much prefer
interactive session
or make points that you'd like to make
so
um i'm going to go ahead and
admit the rest of people in the from the
waiting room
so um let's go ahead and get started oh
one other thing you may have seen it in
the post
if you've been looking for a career
coaching session
um brett ellis one of the career coaches
just
opened some sessions for this weekend so
um since those services are coming to an
end um i suggest maybe that you
if you're looking for a spot and haven't
found one uh check back daily
because sessions can be added every day
in that week or in future weeks
so um i know that the coaches are doing
their best to
open up as many sessions as they can so
uh check back daily for
for a spot okay all right okay
so we're gonna go ahead and get started
here but like i said please interject
if you have a comment to make or a
question and
uh we'll move through the material
pretty quickly i
will have some handouts uh two two
pieces of content that i will have
emailed to you
this week and i'll talk about what those
are
um when we get there so a little bit
of about me um
i am most of my background
is in um human resources
and coaching i was in human resources
for
just a second i'm having a hard time
i was in human resources for over 35
years
uh retired um made a career transition
myself
to to semi-retired about
four years ago now and four years three
years ago
and i've been coaching for uh
approximately six years
and i love the coaching and so i work
part-time and i'm retired the rest of
the time
and so i know what it's like to go
through career changes and transitions
even
though that one was maybe slightly
different
this topic is near and dear to my heart
and one of the reasons
is because i look back and reflect on my
career and realize
that i could have done a better job
planning all along
now as with most of you things
worked out for me i and and i think that
was one of the reasons i didn't plan
is i was generally happy in my career
almost any job i did from you know
office assistant
to benefits manager to director of human
resources
i enjoyed every one of those things and
you know sometimes i felt like those
things just kind of came my way but as i
reflect back
i think there were some reasons those
things happen
so if you're someone who believes in
fate and it'll all work out
i i don't uh uh disagree with that i
think i
you know hold on to those beliefs but i
would say that
um there are some reasons we're going to
talk about today to
actually plan regardless whether you're
happy or not and
you know some of you because you're at
udacity have
consciously decided to make a change and
you're upgrading your skills or you
might love the job you're in
and you just want to build your skills
and
keep up with technology all admirable
things
so um anyway just a second here
okay so um
go ahead and move on tell me
um why you're here today i'd love to
hear that
for some reason you signed
i was up to get um some
direction out of my career search
because i'm i'm
kind of casting a broad net right now i
don't really know
exactly how to approach it and
i could use a little guidance okay okay
i think there may be something in here
today
that um will help you with that i hope
thank you for sharing that john
someone else wanted to speak is that
harvey
yes this is harvey uh i've been
out of the workforce for about 10 years
been a stay-at-home dad
um and i've always wanted to get into
programming or get paid for it i do some
program i've been doing some programming
as a hobby so i
taken the first step of taking
a basic udacity course and programming
just to
demonstrate that i do have the ability
that i'm going to take another course
an intermediate level or advanced course
later to hopefully
launch myself into some type of
programming
either looking at web development right
now or
my heart really is in cyber security but
udacity doesn't offer a lot in those
regards
so the reason i'm here is to uh
basically
refresh the planning
the career planning so that i can focus
myself
uh directly in a very specific path so
that's
what i've come here just is to hear your
insights you've been a coach and you've
been in
uh human resources in this business for
quite some time so i'm here to learn
from you
okay well i think we are going to talk
about some things like focus
and direction and opportunity so
anyway thank you for sharing that great
anyone else care to share before we move
on
okay hi diane this is jana yes
hey um i am currently looking for a
job and it's sometimes very frustrating
so i would love to or what i'm
looking um to like
find or hear in this webinar is
whether i'm doing things right or some
new
tips and ideas how to approach
um you know the whole process
of looking for new opportunities
okay all right great thank you
um again i think we'll touch on most of
these in a general way at the end if we
have time or if i didn't answer a
question directly
um then feel free to email me after the
session
and we'll have a conversation and get
those questions answered but
um all right with that we're going to go
ahead and
move on to the content that i have for
you today here's our agenda
and um we're gonna talk go ahead and
close this bear with me a second mike
there we go okay so we're gonna talk
about regular and intentional career
planning
um we're gonna talk about you know
envisioning the possibilities
um a little bit maybe about you know
like um john has said you know he's cast
a pretty broad net and that's actually a
good thing
at least to start um and to keep open to
possibilities so we'll talk about that
um there are some key things that i um
love to see people make a habit in their
life and networking
is one of those actually uh planning for
your career is another habit that i
think serves us well
if we make it a habit a regular uh
attended to event
um we're going to talk about keeping
things updated and
how it's you know a little bit obvious
but it's easier to do that as you go
along
and rather than waiting until you have
to update and refresh your resume and
then you forget everything you've done
so anyway we'll talk about that we'll
talk about things like practicing
and and getting used to change and and
uh and then have a closing and see if we
can answer any questions at the end so
let's go ahead and
move on
just a um i'm going to move this over
here
all right okay so why is this important
i'd like to hear your thoughts
and maybe you could even tell me if
anyone does regular career planning and
if it's regular how regular how often do
you visit it
and why do you do it thoughts this is
this is harvey
when while i was work
while i was working i i did plan my
career
uh tried to have a goal of where i
wanted to go next
what i what i was looking for next um
and i did that uh throughout throughout
my my work life
and to be honest it wasn't i don't know
that was
uh very intentional it was it was just
kind of having an idea what i wanted to
do and looking for opportunities in
those
in those areas and as you said earlier
you know things just worked out so i
need to be
a little more since i've been out of the
workforce for so long i need to be a lot
more
intentional about it so sure sure okay
and when i say intentional i don't mean
that there is a right and wrong way
um so the things i'm going to cover
today are just ideas for you to consider
there's
there are things i've left out i'm sure
um
and we you can certainly add those uh
any other thoughts about
um why this is important
okay well a couple things that i think
is that
a mantra i like to live by is what gets
talked about
gets done and sometimes it's about what
gets written down gets done
it depends on the person but
i think it's really important to be
prepared
things happen to change over time that's
just the natural course of things and
sometimes these changes are positive we
consider them positive and sometimes
they're
changes we don't want right employers
change or
reorganizations occur and so you know
being ready for the unexpected is one of
the primary reasons
um that i recommend that people um
you know be intentional about this and
be prepared
but even an even better one is to be
ready to take advantage of a new
opportunity that comes your way
and um i would say i was not so good
about this there were things that i
could have better prepared myself for
for when i moved into a leadership role
i always said i didn't want to be in a
leadership role
and then lo and behold i ended up there
and
um i honestly could have done more to
shadow others
envision myself in that kind of role
prepare myself
maybe study a little bit more about that
there was a lot i could have done it
would have made it a little bit easier
for me so it's really about not being
reactionary and being
proactive and then the word intention is
important and why is that
important
john i think intention is important um
in kind of not um
having a direction that you're going in
and why you're going that direction
as opposed to just um applying for
any job or taking any any
opportunity that comes your way
absolutely
absolutely having a purpose a plan
uh something that's specific and i don't
mean to suggest that you can't change
your mind over time you absolutely can
that's gotta be this has got to be a
very fluid process
because our desires change our passions
change we learn new things
but being intentional and specific in
the moment
and that's why you revisit it regularly
so all right we're going to go ahead and
move on
and get a little bit deeper into this
content
um so um
these are some things that i like to
include in
any career plan and the first one
um is really about
and actually i think i have slides on
each one of these
is really assessing the current
situation
okay and to do this it's
sort of about evaluating where you're at
right now
and doing this regularly
someone asked me in the last time i did
this session how regularly and i just
said i
think that it should be revisited at
least once a year
but honestly the ideal would be to have
checkpoints throughout the year whether
that's three times a year or every
quarter
just to check in you don't even have to
once you get the plan figured out
kind of like what are you gonna do to
keep your plan up to date
you can just check in every you know put
it on your calendar and check in
every quarter and just take a look and
what have you done and
and add some things to your portfolio or
your folder or whatever about your
accomplishments but
um this one this slide is really about
sort of an honest assessment of
um you know
how are you doing in your current role
if you have a current role or
whatever you're doing right now even if
you're not
employed or you're doing something on
the side this is an
honest assessment of um from
your perspective of how how are you
feeling about this role is it
challenging
you enough are you learning are you
growing
are you in the flow most of the time
anybody
not know what i mean about being in the
flow in the zone
raise your hand if you know what i mean
okay okay this what i call what this is
for me
is when it doesn't feel like work i'm in
the zone
and and you know i've never had a job
where i was in the
zone all the time i'm not even in that
when i
now as a retiree working part-time um
it's
about do spending a lot of time in that
zone
where it just you love it so much or you
are getting a lot of satisfaction and
it's challenging you at the right level
and so you have a good amount of your
time you wake up in the morning you look
forward to doing what you do
so that's the ideal sometimes we go
through periods where we don't have that
so
an honest and fair assessment about
where are you now
okay um the other thing is to do your
own performance assessment
okay you're gonna have supervisor
feedback you're gonna have a co-worker
feedback
maybe um you're gonna maybe
know where you need to brush up on your
technical and soft skills
but things like what at what level am i
contributing
in this role i'm at now um
and and really um the honest assessment
of your performance um
you know regardless of what your
supervisor has told you
in the past you know um
you need to weigh the facts and the
evidence and here's here's a little
thing i wrote up that kind of walks us
through what you might say to yourself
i am a business analyst at a top tier
tech company
my supervisor's feedback is that i am
doing a very good job
i have great relationships with my team
as evidenced by the fact that they come
to me with questions
fairly often i don't think i'm
contributing as much
as i could be as i am a bit shy and i
have a hard time interjecting my
opinions or ideas
in a group i have about eighty percent
of the technical skills i need to be
successful in this current role
the skills i am lacking are this and
that
whatever that might be anyway keep
the idea here is that you would have
this kind of self-taught conversation
with yourself
um and and you know if you're a person
that
re recalls content best by writing it
down first
then you write it down or you write down
some bullet points of
where you think you are okay and and
this will help you
analyze kind of the skill building piece
of
um well it helps two things it helps the
skill building it also helps you decide
am i
in the right role am i really kind of
challenged by and enjoying my role
enough
and you know the weighting of those
factors is going to
depend on your own personal professional
values so
we'll talk a little bit about that in a
minute any questions
before we move on about that
okay all right
okay all right so the other one
is assessing oh i guess i just did this
sorry uh assessing the levels of
satisfaction that
what i gave you was um was
kind of the lead-in to that but i have a
whole list of questions and this is
one of the handouts i'm going to send
you
after the session i'll have somebody
send it out this week
and these are open-ended questions to
ask yourself
about your level of satisfaction and
again
written responses are sometimes good at
least in bullet form
um there are questions like what is
going well for me in my current
job or career okay
you don't have to write these down
because i'm going to send them to you
also this is going to be recorded so you
can always go back and listen to it
what are three things i really love
about what i'm doing
okay
what are my key strengths and how could
these be utilized in my
how are these being utilized in my
current role
okay and these there's so many questions
i've just given you a few you can come
up with some more on your own
on a scale of one to five with five
being the highest how satisfied overall
am i in my current job career however
you want to
ask that question and then if i could
not continue
in this role for any reason what else
would i
love doing and then again other
questions that you can think of
any questions come to mind that you ask
yourself
when you do this
okay you think of something later you
can interject
okay so here's here's one that may help
a couple of you who answered the
question
um you know i like to encourage
my clients my students to dream big
okay and to keep a mindset of dreaming
big
and dreaming often and of course you
could use this in any part of your life
it doesn't have to just be about your
career
um but um this is somewhat
an exercise and i like to suggest that
people
do a little bit of meditation or
relaxation or just deep breathing
staying present in the moment right
before they do
this exercise it's
a brainstorming exercise and
what's the number one rule about
brainstorming
there are no bad ideas there are no bad
ideas
and you don't evaluate it first right
absolutely thank you harvey perfect okay
all right anybody else have a rule about
brainstorming they like
okay so here are the here are the
the brainstorming questions um
actually maybe i should add those too
i'll try to remember
they're somewhat similar to what i put
on the previous slide
but if i could do anything else besides
what i am doing now what would that be
these are some things you can use for
your brainstorming exercise
and if you could not fail if there were
no mistakes in life which i
tend to believe is true most of the time
what
job or career would you have right now
okay is this resonating with you harvey
given the question that you're asking
yeah it's yeah it's this is this is good
okay
it's all a good refresher okay you've
probably done some of this already right
good i'm glad to hear that okay and as i
dream about my future career and what
ways
am i limiting myself
okay because we tend to do that right we
think well i'm not good at that
or i might not like that i had a client
the other day that said
they were leading a team and they said
um i don't think i'm a good leader and
of course we were at the end of the
session so we didn't get too far on that
coaching but this is the
primary type of topic where using a
coach can help
really teasing out how you're limiting
yourself
and um really asking you know i'd ask
questions like why do you say that
um what do you like about it what do you
don't like about it
um what if you were better than you
thought what are your
what do your subordinates think about
you as a leader so there's all kinds of
questions you can ask yourself
about um ways that you're limiting and
so that's
something i would encourage you to
really give some thought to
you might want to love to or you might
love to do something
and you're evaluating already by saying
i but i can't do that
and so the question to ask yourself is
why can't you do that
um and and you know what makes you think
that
so okay and so choose to remove that
limitation for this exercise
to say if that were not a limitation um
then then what would i do okay so you're
not going to evaluate your answers right
away you're going to make a long list
and just go as far as you can
just keep going until you tell you can't
think of anything else
okay don't try to tie it to your
strengths and your current skills
but do think about what you'd love doing
do think about aligning it with
something
that you'd absolutely that you feel like
you'd be so passionate about it wouldn't
even feel like work
you can do this closed eyed or open eye
um sometimes it's hard for people to get
started so i recommend you use a timer
that's called a pomodoro technique where
you just
set a timer for 10 minutes 15 20
just to get started and you stick with
it sometimes
it takes just five minutes to get
started and then you're in the flow and
you're
into the exercise then reset it for
another 10 15
whatever it helps to keep you focused
make bulleted notes uh it doesn't have
to be pretty these are for you
as long as you can read it okay and keep
all the notes over time you know you can
reflect back
um i i like to recommend that people
get themselves some form of a notebook
and this is your
this is your planning notebook it's your
dream notebook
it's a place you can write things down
ideas you can make checklists
you can just journal about your career
so and then that gives you an
opportunity now to kind of prioritize
and evaluate
and so if having a job and a career that
you love is important to you
then that might be like your number one
value so as you go through this
list of things before you go through and
evaluate
make sure you have kind of your top
three
values what are the most important
things to you about working
it might be family flexibility having a
job that has that kind of flexibility
it might be you know some for some
people it's
prestige and professional uh recognition
um the other things that are high on
many people's list is compensation
levels
uh or just you know putting my talents
and skills to the best you
so that's another thing that you can do
in this and i recommend you do that
before you
evaluate your ideas okay
any questions so far or things that are
we need to clear
up confusion okay okay don't
delete any possibilities but you can
put them in order in terms of priorities
after you've kind of clarified your
values
um all right any other
value statements that you might have
that are important to you
in the career of having the career of
your dreams
i hate i threw out a few i'd like to
hear from a few of you what
one thing that you value about
that's important to you when you choose
a career
for me it's a certain level of autonomy
in
what i do being able to make my own
decisions
great yep that's a good one
anybody else yeah this is harvey for me
it's just uh
that my work is contributing to a
greater good
you're good yeah i hear that often from
udacity students
the autonomy is a big one too within the
tech industry honestly
else those of you who are um
muted um if you want to type in the chat
that'd be
somebody seconded that great okay all
right well we're gonna move on just so
we can get through all the material but
um so again you're gonna you're gonna
order
these things in a map in the order of
priority
um then you might go back through and
decide
okay you know i have two or three things
here that are kind of top priorities in
terms of
possible career paths or next
jobs for me um and
or future jobs hopefully you have short
term and long term and you go through
maybe and just decide and there's no
exact science to this this is
you can make this up whatever seems
logical to you
um but i want you to identify what
might be a most realistic
short-term path or job or role for you
and something that might get you to the
next
most likely and achievable like
something that would get you
closer to your three to five year
desired
goal okay and these are things you're
going to write down on your smart goal
plan that we're going to talk about in a
minute
okay so you're thinking short term long
term and mid-range in terms of
priorities and and don't feel locked in
because you are in charge of this you're
driving this
and you can change your mind okay the
point is to just
get a snapshot in time kind of
perspective
on you know what would really light your
fire
in terms of your career the excitement
around your career
okay all right we're gonna move on to
smart goals and
i'm sure many of you have heard this
before anybody wanna
give me your experience with smart goals
or give me your take on what they are
share with the group
if you've used them raise your hand if
you haven't
that's okay too okay harvey and john
have used smart goals okay give me
one i've forgotten what's smart i've
used it in the past but it's been so
long i've forgotten what smart stands
for
okay okay all right you can you think of
anybody think of one it's an acronym
actually
and there are variations people use
different
uh terms for the acronyms quite honestly
mine'll look different to you probably
than what you've seen before
or the same john anything you want to
share there
okay all right oh go ahead specific
measurable achievable realistic
and time constraint got it yeah that
that is one version of it i
um i think i have most of those on the
next let's just go to the next slide
see how close they are um
uh i think uh what did you have for
our realistic right
is that what you said okay
yeah i said really yeah okay okay so
we're pretty
pretty close again it doesn't really
matter whatever works for you so when
you do your smart goals
you can adapt other acronyms you know
you want to get the gist of this
the point is being specific um
you know we can say okay in five years i
want to have a job that pays
really well and i have lots of
flexibility and autonomy
okay how specific is that
okay you're kind of talking at a values
level which is good that's a great it's
a high level place to start
but it's going to be really hard for you
to focus
and narrow down your steps if you don't
take it a step further and that's why
that brainstorming exercise is so
important
okay framed by your values and and
what you will see on the handout i give
you is just one
template one that i like to use that
looks short term and long term
and being specific about your goals
more specific would be that i
um plan to be in a
and it's uh the language is important
too
in in one year i will be
in a data analyst role um
working remotely for a
top tier tech firm or i might even say
i'm going to be at um i don't know
google or
amazon or whatever that's even more
specific
right again the point is you can you can
change your plan you might end up
somewhere different but if you don't
get specific um it's really hard to
know you know it can feel overwhelming
all right
and then measurable you know how are you
gonna know when you were successful
and that's all that is is is how will
you know when you've arrived
okay it might be a quan quantity kind of
measurement and that's fine
um i'm gonna you know work on these
three skills and to do that
i'm gonna take four courses in this area
and i'm gonna finish it
by such and such a date and
that is very specific and it's
measurable
okay it and then you want to check is
that achievable
as john said sometimes people prefer to
use the word
realistic i have a hard time seeing the
difference between achievable and
realistic i think they're different
though
for most people for me they're not and
that's why i chose to use this
okay so is it possible for me
to achieve that in that short amount of
time
and is it realistic if you'd like to use
that for your
r words um that that i can do this
is this a realistic goal um i always
like to check and say
is my goal or my are my steps
relevant for the goal i'm trying to
achieve
and are they going to give me a result
okay
can i complete that task and will i see
progress towards my result
and then are they time oriented and
you'll see on the
page i'm going to put up next that
they're we always use milestones
okay you start you might start with a
five year plan but then you back and you
just kind of start with the end in mind
stephen covey
popular for saying that um i i love that
thing that he said always begin with the
end in mind
and then you back into your shorter time
frames and milestones okay
any questions so far
i hope this is a new concept for some of
you but if it's not maybe it's just a
good refresher as
to kind of get you focused all right
okay so here's my smart
goals planning tool and
i am going to send you a excel
spreadsheet of this
that will be the other handout that
you'll get
again you can adapt it for your
own use um so take a minute and look at
this and just tell me if you have any
questions
i've even given you some language that
you could
model your own goals with that get
pretty specific
okay
and i think the depth up here where it's
achievable gives you some
uh way to kind of i kind of blended it
with realistic just because of my
difficulty to see that different oh
let me back up okay okay
and then at the bottom what you you know
there are different ways to do this but
what works for me
is that i have some kind of clear
a five-year goal again subject to change
a three-year goal a one-year goal you
can do two and four whatever you want
um i kind of write out how will i know
if i was successful
and then i always like the six month
goals and you may have a goal
on um multiple things this particular
goal
is on job search and career change
okay you might have one on develop
a specific one that's broken down
on something like skill building okay
so even though the overarching goal
could be this job search career
goal you might decide hey i need another
page just like this
for skill building or i might need
another page
just for networking so it depends on how
detailed you want to get but i do
caution you to not spend more time in
planning
than executing okay so what you can do
with this
is you can just you'll notice here that
um it's flex whoops it's flexible
in the sense that you can have your
objectives be
different they can be degree completion
they can be skill building they can be
job search they can be
networking um and
um they have they have a due date
and you're specific about the action
you're going to take okay
any questions about this i'm i'm a big
proponent of doing what works so if this
doesn't format doesn't work for you
you design something that works for you
okay
and again don't get so caught up in the
planning
that you don't actually get things done
okay now you can spend
quite a bit of time in the beginning as
you get comfortable with it
but then you know limit the amount of
time that you spend in planning if
you're going to do
a check-in with yourself every
three months put it on your calendar
designate an amount of time maybe you
set aside an
hour um but if you've already created
your overall plan
maybe you decide i'm only going to spend
about 15 minutes
um in you know or maybe half of the hour
is going to be
on you know reviewing your plan and then
um the second half will be coming up
with
you know kind of measuring and then
really outside of that that's just an
hour and then the next part where you're
going to spend more time is
actually doing the actions that you
outlined sorry i was a little disjointed
there but
hopefully you get the idea okay you over
time you should spend
more time completing the objectives that
are on your plan
down here at the bottom than actually in
the planning mode
okay i love to plan i can get stuck in
planning forever
okay so i know this hazard okay
all right all right so we're going to
move on i'm going to try to
um go through the rest here just a
second
all right so you'll get a copy of that
and then the other thing is
as we talked about revisit this often
figure it out put it on your calendar
career planning is going to happen twice
a year it's going to happen three times
a year
whatever you think you need adjust it as
adjust your plan
as needed build an accountability that's
part of the milestones you'll have due
dates
and don't worry if you missed a due date
by
a certain period and sometimes you'll
have things you decided
hey i don't need to do that anymore that
doesn't make sense
so don't worry about that it's not about
um
you know having something cast in stone
that you have to absolutely do every
single thing the way you described it
the point is to generally hold yourself
accountable
to completing certain things i'm going
to research
what data analyst jobs pay okay i'm
going to research what the market's like
and you might say i'm going to do that
in one month from today
okay try to meet that goal and sometimes
you need to have weekly goals
um i like to use a post-it with
a career planning sheet like that so
that each week i say okay here's my big
plan
and bear with me a second here's my big
and here are four things i need to do
this week
to stay on track with that plan and it's
just very simple two word things okay
because you can always go back to the
plan for a detail
okay and then um you want to stage your
next steps which is an
example what i just talked about um
do this kind of work when it goes best
for you
sometimes it's first thing in the
morning for some people
sometimes it's two o'clock in the
afternoon if this kind of
planning work evaluating work or
actually working
on the things that are on your sheet
you'll know when you have those
productive peaks then schedule it during
that time
don't pick a time when you're totally
drained and you just can't keep going
okay and you can integrate it with other
plans you might
for your whole life have three of those
types of plans okay and then celebrate
your success and celebrate along the way
okay so i want to highlight a few things
particularly since some of the career
services are changing
i hope you already know about this page
but it's out
on the events um website
um and it is an entire list i'm going to
just see if i can
um do this smoothly
apparently not but um there
anybody not know where the youtube
channel of the webinars
is located raise your hand or
say i need to know you don't know where
it is
okay that is going to be i'm going to
i'm going to add that to the list of
what i
send you um you can
find it probably by just searching
udacity youtube
but um
these are the recorded webinars that the
coaches have been doing i think they go
back
a few years and not every webinar but
most of them
and this will be a great resource for
you all as
things are changing with the career
services
because we cover some of this content
okay so i'll make sure to send you
um we'll do the smart goals and the
youtube link so it's easy for you to
find
and a wealth of information out there
from all
some really great coaches all right um
these are two
that if you liked what you heard today
and you want a little more
in-depth detail last year i did two
um april 30th it's up now these numbers
have changed
probably so look for the
there's one that talks about change
but i think it was titled something else
i'll have to send
uh clarify that just a second here i've
got it right here
okay it was on career transition okay
so the april 30th 2020 on career
transition is one i did
that gets a little bit more in depth on
the topic of change
and then january 21st last year
was entitled smart goals i did that one
as well
and so there are many other topics out
there done by
many of great coaches and you'll find
just
really good information on in these
webinars okay
okay so let's go ahead and try to talk
about some specific things that might go
on your your
smart goals spreadsheet or however you
decide to do your
career planning so networking as a habit
i like to say make this a lifelong habit
how many are good at doing this all the
time even when you're not looking for a
job
i'm not either okay this is where i'm
speaking out of both sides of my mouth
here i know i should be better at it
i don't do it as often as i should what
you're doing here
ideally is cultivating relationships and
you know some of the students i've
talked to is like well i feel guilty i
need a job and
why would they want to help me and so i
i like to
encourage you to think about what you
can offer
maybe not right now but um you're
reaching out to people
trying to connect maybe on linkedin when
things open up being able to connect
with people in person
going to conferences attending virtual
events
making a personal connection um you
might yes
be looking for somebody to help you
right now and that's okay you can be
honest
say i really am impressed about what i
see you doing
i'm kind of interested in getting into
that field myself
would you be i'd love to connect with
you on linkedin
would you be a professional partner for
me
hopefully i could return the favor in
the future that's a little bit long you
might choose some of that wording not
all of it
to make your individual connection
and it's just really about relationship
building
and if you do that regularly um
you you do become kind of
professional friends and you
find yourself in a situation where
somebody may call on you for something
so it's a two-way street
uh anybody have anything they want to
add about networking
okay this should always be in your plan
okay
okay keeping um things updated
is really important in my opinion um
you know skills and knowledge
you know make sure these things are
listed somewhere on your
smart goals don't try to tackle
each one each time you work on your
planning space them out over time
you know decide what's most important to
work on
this month next year two years from now
um researching
industry trends and and the mark keeping
up on the market
you might decide hey i'm gonna do some
random searches about these kinds of
jobs
um bye harvey thanks for joining us
all right um
do that industry market research
yourself
because things change okay and so
um i like to recommend that you keep a
file
either on your computer or in a drawer
somewhere
and maybe both and the purpose of that
file and you might title it
you know stuff for my resume or
achievements and you make it easy to put
things in there
it might be something as simple as you
for the you taught a class on some topic
and you don't want to lose sight of that
because the next time it's time to
update your
resume you might forget so any kind of
achievement
or class you finish or
you know certificates then you can
easily put it either in your manual file
if that's easiest you can jot it down on
a
piece of paper date it put what you did
and maybe write some
some other notes about it and just it
can just be a scratch piece of paper and
you put it in the file
okay and then if you might want to have
the
same thing on a computer because
sometimes you get things by email it's
easier just to put them in there
so then you go to both of those files
when it's time to update your resume or
apply for a job
and pull them out and say oh wow i
forgot all about this okay this is
something you can put on your resume
so anyway
and then keep your linkedin profile up
to date
okay here are some things that i
recommend that you practice periodically
so these can be
on your um goal sheet
however you're doing this
for practicing and if you
you know the point being is if you what
if you had an
a new opportunity come your way and you
were so happy in your current role
that you just never applied for a job
you just stayed there you didn't have to
compete for
maybe some of your progression in your
career you didn't have any practice
interviewing i'd run into people who've
had that happen to them for
eight years 14 years 20 years and they
had to do one interview and that was it
um practice interviewing apply
for jobs just because i know that can
get dicey so be a little careful how you
do that but
if you're really not looking to leave
but you never know apply for a job you
might really want to just
explore okay and if an involuntary job
change happens you'll be more prepared
you will have
you know i like to recommend you do
interviewing at least once per year
and if you don't want to apply for a
real job
do a mock interview session okay get a
colleague to help you a coach
maybe even your current supervisor maybe
they're in on your career plans and just
say can we just do
you know that job i want to be this
supervisor in the it department
um we've talked about this can we do a
mock interview for this
just i just want to practice i know
there's not an opening yet
okay go through the process
write your cover letter and that's
another thing to keep in that file
write a draft and then update it
okay even if you're not applying for
anything this takes discipline if you
don't have a reason
to do it so i challenge you to make a
plan to revisit these things
periodically
okay and when you're doing your
interviewing make sure you're practicing
technical and behavioral questions
okay okay
and the kind of the last really
important slide here
is is change getting used to change
um we need to really challenge ourselves
to get out of our comfort zone and try
new things
um you know we want to work through
um this will help us be ready for things
like
what if the unthinkable happened where i
didn't have a choice but they're moving
me to a new role
or i didn't have even have a job
after a certain point getting
yourself out of your comfort zone along
the way
stretching yourself challenging yourself
you know if you're not somebody who
likes to get up in front of people and
talk
or present courses i mean i found myself
there at one point it's like i didn't
really want to do that
and i had to push myself and i got to
love it and i got more comfortable with
it i still have
a long ways to go but i enjoy it
and so um it's good to really
um you know question yourself if you're
given an opportunity to do something in
your role
and you're limiting yourself saying you
know this is i'm not going to do this i
can't do this
i don't want to do it i don't see why
this would help me then i would
encourage you to keep your mind open
and just do it these are the things that
will help you become more resilient and
flexible
and you know one question i get asked
pretty often
uh and i cover this in um one of my
other webinars
is people who are midlife and beyond say
you know
ageism feels like it's alive and well to
me
how do i avoid this and the one thing i
tell them is
you know in my experience and i i can't
speak for every hiring manager the
important thing is to
remain flexible and resilient be open to
change
um those are the kinds of
characteristics that i would hire for
regardless of somebody's age i'm really
looking for
anyone who is open to doing things
different
learning new things staying flexible
keeping their skills relevant
over time and not afraid to try new
things
those are the biggest things you can do
to combat what
sometimes people call agent ageism okay
and i think that i talk a little bit
more about that in the career transition
webinar that's posted out there it was
done on april 30th
2020. okay all right and keep track of
how you challenge yourself
put change on your uh smart goals
spreadsheet
okay change um
spell out some ideas you have right now
for how could i
get myself more comfortable with change
what are some thoughts you have and then
as those opportunities come up
or others other opportunities just go
for it and then you can write it down as
an accomplishment
and this helps you get more comfortable
be intentional about
getting used to change and if you need
help working through it
you know get some help you know whether
that's a coach a counselor a
colleague a supervisor and then
do some what if and backup planning okay
all right so i know we moved through
that pretty quick
we've got just a couple of minutes any
burning questions
or comments or thoughts that you want to
share
hi this is patrick um uh
sorry i came late i was confused about
the
timing and okay
we'll be have a recording of this so you
can
yes yes so i can check it later okay yes
this will be recorded and um
posted out on the youtube site um
you should get an email um i'm gonna
send
two handouts and a youtube link
out to the people who participated today
um the youtube link is also there in the
slides
um so you can look at the recording if
you need to get get it later
but um it's uh let me see if i can just
go there right now i just want to show
you
bear with me a second i'm um oh
not good at this maybe somebody can help
me here so let's see
i wanna i wanna do a new share oh there
we go
okay right here
nope nope that's not what i want to
share uh
just a second well i'm not good at this
so i'm just
[Music]
see i should really challenge myself to
do it but
uh for some reason i need to exit the
slide presentation i know that there we
go
all right see i figured it out i think
it's right there there it is
okay can you see that
i think i've got something else let me
okay there we go look at all those okay
okay overcoming imposter syndrome
finishing i gotta get this out of my
um making the movie yeah
okay so you can see the link right up
here youtube.com
and it is a udacity channel i'm not sure
what this all means but that's the link
that i'm going to give you
okay and these go back
fireside chat that one's a good one that
was an outside presenter
personal branding anyway
take advantage of these these are out
there as far as i know they will be out
there indefinitely
um for you and they go back years and
years
okay
okay well i'm gonna leave you with that
thank you all for participating
uh you're a wonderful group and i wish
you all the best
uh i mentioned this at the beginning but
if you're looking for a coaching session
um since i know they're ending this on
march 24th the coaching sessions anyway
um brett ellis just opened up a bunch on
the weekend
and i encourage you to check back daily
as coaches will be opening some up as
they can fit them
in okay so i hope you're able to take
advantage of at least one or two more
before the
program ends any other questions
oh thank you john that's what i needed
to do
thank you appreciate it john posted the
link
you guys great
all right take care it was nice meeting
you all and have a wonderful rest of
your day
thanks diane yes thank you're welcome
my pleasure take care best of luck to
everyone
[Music]
you